foreign
hypochondriac her dad died of brain
cancer her mom was diagnosed with breast
cancer in the years past her grandfather
had throat cancer and her grandmother
has cop this is the the demon of anxiety
it's kind of right
[Music]
Tony show the greatest mental health in
marriage and parenting podcast that's
ever existed
telling me if we just keep saying it
over and over it's going to become true
so glad you've joined us uh if you want
to be on this show let me know what's
going on in your life whether you got
trauma you got to deal with you've got
parenting issues you've got problems
with your kids schools what's going on
at your universities with your kids
whatever's going on your life give me a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a s k all right let's go to Ria in
Alberta Canada what's up Ria
good morning thank you for having me on
Dr John of course how are you you sound
so loud thank you
so um my issue is weight
um I gotta give you a little background
I have been uh Dave Ramsey uh follower
since 2007. I saw him at an event in
2007 in Salt Lake City and I kind of
have been on the program ever since one
time I had a fall off but I got back on
uh Hey way to go sir have you paid you
don't owe anybody any money
done wow here we go
yeah house paid off got Investments you
don't have a house payment
no house payment no house payment no no
um credit card nothing hey do people
listen to the show there's there's a big
chunk of our listeners that don't know
don't don't know what like the Dave
Ramsey program
tell them what it feels like to not have
a house payment and if you got inflation
you got Christmas coming up I know
oh it's gas is more expensive it's
annoying it's not a choice between gas
or or food right
yeah yeah it is and and you know what
sometimes I mean this Christmas is going
to be a little tight yeah but it you
know
um so I'm 75 I've got five kids 14
grandkids but
um they all know the grandma is not
going to be a cash cow this this year
and I just couldn't live with live
within my means that means you you've
also over the years of paying all your
debts off you've also learned how to
have hard conversation not hard
conversation but just direct
conversations right
that's so great you're incredible Ria so
how can I help you you mentioned wait
how can I help you
[Music]
on a farm I was the oldest one in the
family so I helped with Farm chores I
was always kind of a stuck your build
like you know not real Slim Trim 100
pound my my frame is not okay small and
so I always grew up kind of
with a little self-esteem I mean I was
127 pounds for all of high school where
all the other girls were 115. like that
you know
um so I think the people my grandmas
were not hold on hold on hold on did
were people ugly to you or was this
something in your mind were people mean
to you
no
I think maybe it was in my mind okay and
I say in your mind like you're not crazy
or anything like that but no no uh the
difference between 115 and 127
I know is not a great it's not a
significant Gap right no
um so maybe to a 14 year old oh make no
mistake about that right so I'm I'm not
trying to minimize it what I'm trying to
I'm trying to get at is was this
something you sensed in yourself or were
people making fun of you were they
laughing at you was your mom always
making comments was your mom always on a
diet and your dad making comments about
her and you you you absorbed some of
that that's what I'm getting at yeah
yeah my mom was always on a diet
absolutely I don't think my dad ever
made a comment and I don't think so okay
but your mom was always talking about
weight and was always on a diet and yes
partition a pear tree okay okay yeah
yeah so you're 75 you've had a a a
remarkable life you've got grandkids
your own kids
and here we are yeah and you know I'm
really I mean I've had some hard stuff
um my oldest daughter passed away when
she was 15 from cancer it was not
diagnosed properly and she passed away
my husband died in a car accident
um you know
um I did go for counseling after
after you know a number of guests in the
family I did go for counseling a couple
of different times but it was more in
grief counseling and it was it was
astounding how much good that did oh
good
um I tried to go back with the same well
it was two different counselors actually
did two different times I tried to go
back and talk with them about the weight
because I still think I have that
self-esteem issue in fact I know I do
okay
um but bottom line they are so busy that
an issue of what I'd like to lose is
about 30 pounds maybe a little bit more
okay but it's just enough to make me
fluffy instead of streamlined and I want
to be streamlined because that's I will
feel better about Ria okay
so so I had a gas gastroplasty and it's
part it's partially helped yep okay how
much did you lose after that
okay and have you maintained it
no okay so it came back it came back
plus or to come back about about level
um about level no no no no I was 240 I'm
180. and I'd like to get down to about
150. okay so you're still down
significantly
oh yeah absolutely okay all right
okay so there's a lot to unpack here and
I'm gonna try to do it in as dig like as
I said I was gonna say bite size and
then I was going to say digestible and I
don't want to make food references they
were just for what was coming out okay
um I'm gonna try to make this
um
as simple as possible is that cool
perfect thank you
um I could talk nerd all day we could
call some ex like we could talk nerd all
day let's get to the meat and potatoes
here and again there's yet another food
reference sorry about that so
um
there's a an extraordinary man who is
also a great actor his name is Ethan
suply
and he has
um documented a just an astounding
weight loss and not only weight loss but
just a personal transformation
and my friend uh Dr Lane Norton who's
one of the most the one of the
um
Premier voices in the world on nutrition
and weight loss and building muscle and
taking care of your body
um he told me
that Ethan one time said this
when the house is on fire
that's not the time to try to figure out
why the house is burning
like where did the fire start why did it
start when the house is on fire we just
need to get out
let's just get out of the house
and then when the fires burned itself
out then we send in the the arson
investigators the engineers the whoever
to go in and then to do to figure it out
so that it doesn't happen again right
yep so similarly
you can and you've done the work you've
thought through this a lot about where
did this idea that Ria is less than
where did that start yeah and you've
you've pinpointed it as a 12 year old
little girl working on a farm that you
were a little bit bigger than the other
girls in your class and that may just
outside feel outside of the bounds a
little bit my guess is it's deeper than
that
and also my guess is
at this point at 75 doesn't matter
okay let's do the things that we know
are going to help
and I I'm going to tell you all that
with one giant caveat okay and this is a
hard caveat
if you lost 30 pounds in the next 30
days
you know who would be there
Maria
true
and if you lost 50 pounds Rhea goes with
you too
so I want to promise you
that you'll feel that you'll see that
number on the scale and you'll feel so
proud and good for a minute
and then you'll look at Maria
till you make peace and love her
regardless of what that scale says
you're going to be Chasing Ghosts
okay okay
the Ria I've got to talk to today
is incredible
you've been through hell and back a
bunch of times you grew up in Canada for
God's sake I grew up in Texas and they
told us at church hell was hot I don't
believe that I think it's cold and
Canada sounds a lot right it's you've
been through so much
and you can sit back and look at your
family
and you're going to have a house full of
knuckle-headed little grandkids in a
couple of couple of weeks
yeah you've been a part of changing your
family tree and changing your family's
Legacy
and as an outsider I see a lot of
reasons to love Ria
she's an oppressive woman
okay
so the first thing I want you to do
before we do anything else
we get off the phone over the next
couple of days
is I want you to write a letter to that
12 year old little Ria
um and I want you to tell Ria
what you think of her
and I'm gonna ask you to be really kind
to that 12 year old little girl because
you wouldn't talk to her the same way
you talked to Growing Up Rio would you
no no
that little 127 pound 12 year old girl
was beautiful was a hard worker it was
probably hilarious and probably had to
deal with some of her mom's
demons too right yes
and that 12 year old little girl you
know what she deserves to look in the
mirror and just smile from ear to ear
and be absolutely in love with herself
because she's beautiful and she's fun
and she's silly and she's goofy and she
doesn't need to absorb mom's weight
issues and mom's personal struggles and
Mom's trauma that she endured as a young
girl and all that
but here we are so I want you to write
12 year old Ria a letter
tell her that you love her
until you're proud of her
Let Her Off The Hook okay
yes all right so that's step number one
step number two is we're gonna focus on
we're gonna practice in this upcoming
new year
on a new identity
you are not Ria the overweight lady
you are going to be Ria the woman who's
a good Steward of her body
okay ah let's pretend you got 25 years
left
I'm a good Steward of my body I'm gonna
take care of it that means I'm gonna
move
I'm gonna exercise some I'm gonna I want
to be able to and I'm 85.
to kick my grandkids little booty all
over the living room floor when we
wrestle that's what we're aiming for
okay so we are going to become a good
Steward of our body that's our identity
not we're fat and we have to get smaller
so that we can finally love who we are
that's not gonna work
we're going to become a steward of our
body and if we are a good Steward of our
body our weight will take care of itself
okay
yeah so I want you to spend some time
over the next couple weeks before the
new year rolls over asking yourself
what's going to make me a good Steward
of my body
and let me tell you uh we're gonna get
through some of the details down here
but this is important this last weekend
my church had a potluck I love potlucks
y'all have those in Canada
absolutely oh man in my favorite part of
the church potluck
is the card table full of desserts
and because I've been I've got a great
friend in Dr Lane Norton who has been
really direct with me and been a real
blessing to me
you know what I did
I went in at lunch and I had my lunch
and I annihilated that dessert table
I I at one point I sat down and my wife
looked at me and her eyes got big and I
said I'm making poor choices and I know
and she said okay just wanted to make
sure you were conscious and and at
dinner
I had a small omelette because like a
budget I'd spent my money at lunch
I didn't save it for dinner and you know
what the next day I was down 1.2 pounds
oh okay so I want to tell you that
sometimes being a good Steward of your
body is just having a great day
okay it's not always torture and it's
not restriction all the time and it's
not hatred as my my friend Sal over at
mind pump said you can't hate your body
into making it looking better
that's not sustainable
it's like hating your husband into
loving you more that just doesn't work
okay yeah
so
we're going to start with a new identity
we're going to be a good Steward of our
bodies for as long as we've got it left
okay here's the second thing awareness
and intentionality
there's a gap between stimulus and
response between all of a sudden I miss
my husband
or when your daughter's birthday rolls
around and you miss her
or one of your grandkids calls and says
granny I got a C instead of an a
and your default setting might be to
grab
a cookie or to go to the store or to get
a large Coke and pour the whole thing
right
that's an absolute default okay so
here's what we're doing we're just gonna
look for the some space just a gap
between that initial feeling and I'm
reaching for it last night as and I'm
learning this I'm practicing this right
along with you okay I'm no I'm not obese
I'm not struggling but I am trying to
get control of my intentionality
yesterday I was on the phone having a
conversation on the way out the door I
grabbed off my boss's desk he's got a
bowl of candy I grabbed a box of Milk
Duds
and I started walking out and just
before I opened them
I had that space and I set him down on
his admin's desk so I carried them for
about 15 feet
and it was just a gap between stimulus
and response between I'm having a hard
conversation uh I picked these up I
don't want these I'm gonna set these
down okay that's what we're looking for
just a Gap a big part of that is
tracking okay and so here's a cool thing
my friend Dr Lane Norton has what I
think has been a blessing to me my
friends are on all using it now
um
it's the single best
tracking app for what we eat in the
world it's called carbon c-a-r-b-o-n
and he is going to gift you a lifetime
membership you can have it forever
okay
so I want you to hang on the line it was
think Dr Norton it's it's been a
blessing to me and I called them last
night and said hey would you be willing
to gift this it's been such a blessing
to me to to this caller I've got
tomorrow and he said absolutely
um and so you'll stay on the line we'll
get your contact info and it's just an
app that you log into and it tracks your
protein and your calories it just it
helps you be intentional about what
you've eaten over the course of a day
and I thought I was eating about a
thousand calories less than I actually
was
and so there's been a few weeks a few
months where I've had to learn like I'm
not starving I'm not hungry
I'm just used to this space being filled
up with Gummy candies and Milk Duds all
right yes yes and I just have to feel
what that feels like ah feels good
or it feels not great but I'll be all
right see what I'm saying
yes it's the single best
uh weight loss app not even weightless
app it's a coaching app and it's
incredible but I'm gonna give it to you
okay you put on your smartphone and you
can just carry around with you and it's
going to be something that you practice
with okay and
um you're gonna have to come up with
here's number three some sort of
restriction that you can live with
some do vegans some do keto some do what
I don't care what it is but at some
point you're gonna have to say I'm
through I spent my money for today and
money is just calories right I've spent
them for the day and so um I had a
humongous breakfast full of pancakes and
bacon and cool
um I'm gonna have a really light light
dinner I'm gonna go for a walk right
because I spent my money today it's just
like a budget except it's calories okay
um and then the final one is a part of
our stewardship of our bodies we're
going to we're going to move whether
that's exercise whether it's going to
the local YMCA whether that's getting in
one of those swim those like water
aerobics Group whatever that is I'm just
gonna commit to movement it might be me
walking around my yard
okay yeah I love to I love to walk when
there's no ice yeah yeah I just gave me
a bike no my kids gave me a recumbent
bike for Christmas great so I've got no
excuse there you go hey watch your
favorite show
there we go put it on there which it was
which Dr deloni right
that's going to make you pedal really
slow it's kind of a it put you to sleep
all right here's the last last thing I'm
Gonna Let You Go okay
okay the last thing is I want you to
write 75 year old Rio letter
and I want you to tell 75 year old Ria
how proud of her you are
how much you love her
I want you to be hug that woman for the
hard stuff she's been through hug that
woman for the great stuff she's for the
hard choices she said to make over the
years for the
her ability to pay off all her debts and
have hard conversations with her kids I
want you to
write 75 year old real letter a reminder
that she's not a failure her whole life
hasn't been a shame she hasn't screwed
up everything
she's a really cool lady
thank you is that cool
yes it is all right I am I cannot be
more grateful for you thank you for
calling for sharing your journey with us
thank you for
being brave
thank you for letting that 12 year old
little girl go play for the first time
in a long time and thank you for loving
my friend 75 year old review
and big shout out to Dr Lane Norton and
his team like the incredible carbon app
go check it out where you get apps it's
worth it if you're thinking about losing
weight in the coming year or you want to
start lifting weights more whatever your
goals are check it out carbon um and I
by the way I have no Financial
affiliation this thing at all none zero
I make zero dollars off of this thing I
just use it personally and I believe in
it um in in a deep and profound way
um Ria you're awesome everybody will be
right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor better help let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help betterhelp is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back let's go to Paul
and welcome to Miami what's up Paul
hey how you doing Dr John I'm good man
what's up
oh not much uh live in a Jimmy Buffett
day and relaxing at home Cheeseburger in
Paradise baby that's right that's right
so what's up thank you for taking my
call you got um I'm calling because my
wife is a self-diagnosed hypochondriac
I love you
and I'm sure your wife is awesome but I
think we can all agree that
self-diagnosed hypochondriacs whoa
and uh she also states she loves going
to the doctor oh gosh
hey here's a
I'm saying oh gosh not because she's
dumb or a [ __ ] or somehow less than
I'm saying oh gosh because I know how
hard this is in your home and I know how
miserable it is for her and how
miserable it is for you y'all got little
ones too
nope no little ones not yet
um but uh oh boy thanks for the future
okay
so she's got Health anxieties Fair yes
yeah Health anxieties uh she she does
have General anxieties as well
um she gave me a list of active worries
that she has okay and then you always
say to lead with the big thing so I
could I could do both of those if you
like go for it
so uh to caveat she did say she does say
this started at a young age this
self-diagnosed hypochondriac sure um but
her active worries are all forms of
cancer okay heart failure blood clots
brain aneurysms covid any lung or heart
issues from covid and pneumonia to name
a few cool and the big thing the big
things are three years ago her dad died
of brain cancer okay uh this past year
her mom was diagnosed with breast cancer
okay
um in the years past her grandfather had
throat cancer and her grandmother has
COPD okay
so
um this is the the demon of anxiety
is uh
it's kinda right
right so I don't want to parse apart
health anxiety versus generalized
anxiety I think that can be a an
academic waste of most of our time okay
your wife struggles from anxiety
I've been there debilitating it's hard
it messes up stuff
one of the things we've seen in the
medical community over the last 15 or 20
years is an increase of people with pain
disorders and who are struggling from
like I think oh I think my heart rate is
racing I need to go to the doctor
because often
that's the only place where somebody
stops what they're doing and puts their
phone down and looks at them in the eye
for 15 minutes or gently touches their
skin takes their blood pressure
right it's much more about human
interaction or it's as much about human
interaction as it is about the
diagnostic
okay
that's a body screaming for connectivity
um so she grew up as an anxious kid
where did that come from Mom Dad who
um well from what she's told me she did
have
um in my own opinion some significant
trauma through a childhood
um she was sexually abused by an older
sibling I know you've talked about
screaming a lot in uh for children and
she was in a household with a lot of
screaming and she's never been very
close with her mom okay so she's got a
lot in that sweet little body of hers
okay and the manifestation is some
people dig holes in the ground and
create underground bunkers
and some people hoard things and protect
themselves with stuff
and some people respond to anxiety
um by shutting the drawing the shades in
and get under the covers and netflixing
themselves to death
um I tried to solve my anxiety with
information
it's really cool to tell people I've got
two phds it's also a trauma response
okay it was me trying to prove that I
was smart and it was me trying to get
more data and more data and more data
and more data she happens to try to
solve her anxiety from being
uh
uh over the top in tune with her
physiological functions to the point
that she's lost perspective
and she seeks the comfort of somebody
she views as wise and someone who finds
value in her which is a medical
professional or a nurse or a doctor
right
sure okay so
she's gonna have to decide
this is a person who uh
if I say if I say um I want you to write
your fears down and then demand evidence
from them
when you're in the throes of deep
anxiety she's got all the evidence she
needs every one of her family members
has died of cancer or has cancer right
that's right so she's got all the data
she needs yeah well we've talked about
that exactly because because we listen
to you every day and so we've talked
about that as a team together and she
says well I can find the evidence that's
right so so yeah I'm going to go back to
um something my buddy Todd told me and
I've told us I've mentioned on the show
and I'll mention again because it was
such a shape shifter for me might not be
helpful for anybody else
but one of my deep worries was the
implosion of the financial system
I didn't understand it I still I still
don't understand it but I didn't
especially understand it then and it
didn't make sense to me and things that
didn't make sense to me were a threat to
me and then I start trying to solve
things that didn't make sense to me and
that's even makes even less sense
because I don't even know how it works
I'm trying to solve something I don't
know how it works but
I was sitting down with him grilling him
one day and here's the other thing I'm
not dumb and here's the other thing
we're in the middle of a mat it was 2009
2010 during the middle of the madness so
I had all the evidence I need this whole
thing's going down this whole thing's a
shame this whole thing's on a house of
cards and we're going through this thing
and this thing I was like what about
this and what if this happens what if
this happens and then finally he said oh
dude I don't have a meteorite plan
and I was like what do you mean and he
said well I do all the things I know to
do right now which I carry no household
Consumer Debt he paid his house off
um I have this and I've got an emergency
fund and I don't have any debt on my
cars and I put money in retirement here
and I've got a couple of rent houses
over here
and then if the monetary system goes
away I'll deal with that when it happens
and for some reason it was a light bulb
moment for me because I wasn't taking
care of all the other things that I
actually could control I was just trying
to catch a spaceship which I couldn't do
and so I channeled my energy over time I
had to learn how to do this into all
right well I guess I'll go see a
counselor and I guess I will start
hanging out with my friends again
because I need relationships and I guess
I'll get my debts paid off because I
know that you can't be non-anxious if
you owe people money because your
brain's screaming at you you're not safe
You're Not Safe you're not safe so I
started taking care of the little things
and it was amazing
how the big stuff kind of evaporated
and here's what I mean in my house
I got a family history of cancers got a
family history of heart stuff some of it
I didn't even know about until recently
and so I get my blood taken every year
by a great doctor Dr Vickery and we go
through it and it's expensive we go
through the whole thing and he does a
incredible job my wife does too
and I take really good care of myself
best I can unless I'm having a gummy
candy day
and so I'm doing all the things that I
know to do
and then I'm gonna if I get throat
cancer I get throat cancer you know what
I mean I don't have a meteorite plan for
that after I'm gonna do the things
that I'm going to be intentional about
longevity so here's what I'm telling you
she's going to have to choose
to be less miserable in the present
not rehearsing tragedy for a thing that
may happen someday
sure right and and I think it comes down
I think some of it might be a control
thing as well
no no no don't I I wouldn't go there I
wouldn't go there yeah it is but you're
talking about a little girl who is
sexually abused and that little girl's
still in there
so yes she is trying to seek control of
something because the things that we're
supposed to love her the most her
brother
her mom and dad they didn't show up
so yeah she's trying to control
everything I think my question would
come to how to be a good husband there
we go when when she brings up a concern
because I think I've gone through
different uh I don't know ways of trying
to support her best and and now I'm I'm
just wondering is if she comes with a
concern a health consumer a very
specific Health concern
what's the best way I could I could
support because right now what it is is
if she brings a very specific Health
concern I'll say okay well why don't we
go to a specific doctor and get that
checked out but I'm not sure if that is
a long-term solution no because that
becomes self-reinforcing
meaning
she gets anxious she gets anxious she
gets anxious y'all both go do a thing
that you know is really
not a good use of medical resources of
the doctor's time and of y'all's time
and money but you're gonna go do it
because it's gonna make her feel better
right this moment
and what it does is it reinforces the
anxiety that the way to feel better is
to go do this thing and then so your
body you see what I'm saying it starts a
loop that your body's going to start
seeking out these things every time
sure and so when I say the only way to
heal is through it
it's to uh oh I just woke up and I think
I'm I think I'm having fill in the blank
sure right and since we've already got a
blood test we're going to get a baseline
test since we've already got a cancer
screening since we've already done a an
echocardiogram so and I am suggesting go
get a good Baseline like an a great
blood to get a good Baseline
sure so that
um when the field I think this thing you
can roll back to
oh we just like 60 days ago we got this
great um Baseline here
yeah and we do we do annual physicals
great and and it came up to where uh
maybe a month ago she said well that's
been six or eight months ago you know
things can change
and so it's it's kind of it's kind of
like she would like to go again that's
right and so those are the moments
we are going to breathe and we're going
to head right into the storm meaning
we're going to feel that anxiousness
we're gonna know that our bodies are
okay
we're going to hold Loosely a meteorite
that might be coming you're right we
could have had 10 years of great blood
tests and then you got eight eight seven
eight months and then bam
stage four throat cancer
right right
um I'm not a cancer doctor
um
but that you see you you recognize she
recognizes how unlikely that is right
yeah she does and and I've always I've
always said you know at any point if you
want me to help you find a therapist but
I'm happy to but I know I can't push her
into it I know that from listening to
you it has to be a decision she has to
come to on her own right and so what we
need to do is when she's not anxious
we need to come up with a game plan that
y'all are both going to
shake hands and agree on
because just running to Specialists to
Specialists for the rest of her life is
going to become cost prohibitive and it
really is taking resources from somebody
else who needs to be there
and we don't want to blow over if she
actually is having an incident she does
have an increased risk for cancer
because she's got it in all of her
family members all right right
um she does possibly have an increased
risk for filling the blank so sit down
with somebody and map that out
and I definitely think Cena counselor is
important I think if she won't go
then you go on your own and if she asks
you are you going tell her I want to
learn some better tools on how to
relationally connect with somebody who's
struggling so deeply from anxiety
okay what you're going to be tempted to
do is to create a Universe on your own
a world that's not crazy a world that's
a little more stable and what she's
going to do is feel you by degrees one
degree two degree three degrees she's
going to feel you pulling away and
that's going to spark up the anxiety
even more
sure okay so when you say what's the
greatest thing you can do I can tell you
don't try to solve her as though she's
like an engine issue
lean in relationally and you'll have to
have already planned out what that looks
like when she comes to and says I think
I'm having a stroke
already have planned out
all right let's hold hands both of them
I'll stop what I'm doing I'm closing all
the screens I'm turning the game off
even though it's the fourth quarter
there's only two minutes left I'm gonna
lean into this relationship
so we're going to breathe together I'm
going to connect with you together
and then once our breathing's under
control
then we're going to walk through okay
what are the three things are we gonna
go for a walk right now and while we're
walking we're gonna take five minutes of
just doing box breathing while we're
walking and then after minute five we'll
talk through symptoms
tell me why you think let's be curious
tell me why you think you're having a
stroke
yeah right and we're just gonna practice
that but listen you're you're right on
she's got to decide
I want to be less anxious
I want to heal from my anxiety
my health anxiety
and
ah jeez don't diagnose yourself as
hypochondriac please that's so hard
don't give yourself yet another label
yet another diagnosis
body's trying to keep you safe it has
been for a long time
and
to your
to your wife Paul I'm sorry that her
family didn't show up for family heard
her
and she's lucky to have you a guy that
loves her so much
so we're gonna have some anxiety healing
and some trauma healing and some
practicing some new behaviors
to your sweet wife she's watching this
you deserve to be well and you deserve
to be loved you deserve to stop
feeling like your body's failing you the
people in your life they did they failed
you they abused you they hurt you
screamed at you made it your fault
[Music]
but you're good
and you're whole
and you're worth being well
we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-o-p.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
all right we are back let's go to all
right so we got a husband a wife
there has been a wife
yes okay so I'm gonna bring them both on
this is scary for me all right let's
take uh we're gonna first we're gonna go
to Faith because you gotta have faith
the faith the faith what's up Faith
hey Dr John thanks so much for taking
our call of course all right hang on I'm
gonna bring in
the mighty p-h-i-l Phil is that cool
yeah all right Phil you there
I am how's it going are you all in the
same house I'm great are you all in the
same house
we are yep oh this is incredible okay at
some point one of y'all has to say
something really mean about the other
one but you can't do anything you should
always assume how it's awesome okay so
what's up what's up
hey okay so this is gonna take a little
backstory
um but I'll just jump off with our
question we are wondering how can we
develop and set healthy boundaries to
protect our marriage and family as we
consider moving in with my dad and my
siblings still at home
okay tell me more
okay so
um a year ago
um actually January of 2021 we got some
devastating news that my mom
um had esophageal cancer we thought
there was hope and she went through
treatment but November of 2021 we lost
her
um and it was just an awful year
um
so my parents had adopt they have eight
children four biological I'm the second
oldest and then for adopted
um and of the eight kids there are still
three at home
um my 18 year old brother a 10 year old
sister an 11 year old brother wow okay
so they're still like yeah I mean your
dad's still he's still full full contact
parenting okay yes uh
um
and my little Louis brother has a lot of
um
needs he is paralyzed from the waist
down
um and just very immunocompromised
um she's doing better as he's gotten
older but a lot of physical needs and
emotional
um trauma and anger and and then add on
the grief of losing your mom
um so then the sister is doing okay but
the 18 year old brother is also
really hurting and exhibiting those
behaviors and then my dad
um it struggles with bipolar disorder
um growing up he really did a great job
of coping with it as a dad and just
having
handling it well but my mom was his big
support and
um so now she's gone and
so in this last year may have been nice
uh we also we have a little boy and then
we're expecting a baby congratulations
because why because why not y'all should
get a puppy too yeah might as well might
as well just throw it all in
um yeah so we we have been the siblings
that have been in a place that's able to
help wanting to help
um what what is that what does that mean
you've got income y'all are the only
couple that's married and likes each
other like what is you're able to help
what does that mean okay
Okay so
uh we
I am a stay-at-home mama okay
um so and then Phil now work from home
his job just transferred so he works
full-time
um in his office but he's home with us
um
and two days a week we have the kids
over here after school
um we so I guess when I say we're the
only ones able my I might have an adult
brother who lives at home but he is also
working full-time and
um seeking to move forward with his own
life and then I have an adult sister
um who's married and has a baby but they
are this very consumed with their own
family and you you're so very very
nicely
very nicely you have said
your other siblings want nothing to do
with this mess
and
you have transposed on yourself as we're
the only ones who are able to as you're
the only ones who will
can we call that is that fair I know you
don't like to talk bad about people I
can tell it in your voice you're the
sweetest person on planet Earth but
that's the truth right
right yes okay there we go there she is
all right so
your brothers your your siblings have
left the building
and it's just you and you're watching
your dad slowly get pulled under water
and you're watching these little kids
slowly have to deal with the their
bipolar dad and the death of their
mother and yeah and the adoption stuff
which is hard on kids all of it all the
same time
and so you and your husband you and Phil
have decided we're going to move in
we're going to move our infant
and our young kids
into this house and we're gonna help
yeah I'm not saying Hey listen none of
that none of that is bad I'm not saying
don't do that I just want to be like
really clear about here's what we're
saying right is going to be the solution
to this okay
and and I do want to see so my brother
who lives at home she
he has recognized like hey there is
probably more ways that I could support
and he's actually the one that is a
valid a faithful listener to you and I
was like say you need to start listening
and so I did and then I decided to email
and yeah yeah that's right all right so
what what is this dieting what does
looking like moving in what like moving
in what does that look like Phil I
haven't heard from you you're being
intelligently quiet right now
I I try my best to get me safe
keep you safe so what what like what
walk me through what you
are what I have experienced
yeah so
um so about a year ago uh when uh our
mom first uh when she initially passed
away uh the idea had come up about
possibly moving in to just help around
the house and it was immediately shot
down we had zero interest
um at that point who brought it up who
brought it up
um I think Faith might have and then
just other people
um in our life had kind of like
mentioned the idea okay
um but so at the time we just kind of
shot it down our son was
um five six months old at the time
um and it just we just didn't think it'd
be good at the time
um a couple months ago now
um the idea kind of resurfaced we had
some other uh people we look up to in
our lives kind of bring up the idea
again especially kind of after reviewing
the year and kind of hoping you know
things would progress we would start to
move forward as far as her dad's
household is concerned
um and we just continue to see
kind of the same issues
um and things going on most of the most
recent of which being
um that the 18 year old brother who was
still living at home has actually moved
in with us
um and uh just him and dad had a bit of
a falling out and
um the dad actually approached us
um and asked if you know and said hey
you know it's not working at home right
now and we just kind of decided faith
and I to take him in
but so ultimately ultimately yeah so
let's do let's do this let's drill down
how can I best help
sure so I think I think the biggest
thing is
um we we understand faith and I we've
prayed a lot about it and truly feel
God's leading towards it um that that
moving in
um to their house is one of the best
ways we can help and is is what God's
leading us to so with that
um we know that it could be very easy
for attention to arise
um for miscommunications to happen and
so what faith and I are really seeking
to do is figure out
the best um how to clearly communicate
and and what boundaries we need to have
in place to make sure that we're
maintaining our own family because that
has to be our number one priority
um but also to
um helping their family uh in in the
best way that we can
all right excellent all right so I'll
run through these and I'm writing them
down real quick
um
uh and all right so the first and most
important thing here is none of this
works if your marriage falls apart
so Cornerstone number one is you and
faith faith you're there y'all two
getting somewhere no kids except for the
one that you're is in the oven now
and deciding what kind of marriage we're
going to have
and I would recommend be real real
specific
we will go on a like obviously about to
have a newborn so that just throws all
this into a blender but
we will go on dates like this this many
times a week
um after we are back to sleeping
together we're gonna have sex this many
times a week and so this is what we're
gonna have to do to make that a reality
we are
um here's how our finances are going to
be separate from this endeavor we're
taking on
here's who's gonna do laundry here's
who's gonna do X and y's see what I'm
saying we are going to be really Crystal
Clear he's going to shop
really crystal clear about uh retirement
our saving for our kids college because
it's real easy for this whole thing to
get real blurred together
and suddenly Phil you're arguing with
her about her dad but suddenly you're
defending this 11 year old which made
her mad and she spent money over here to
buy groceries for everybody you see I'm
saying you wake up in 10 years and y'all
are
just everything's in Ash see what I'm
saying so the first conversation is
marriage has to go first
the second thing is is you said it great
how are we going to protect our nuclear
family inside of this thing because you
have an infant and you're about to have
a newborn
and infants and newborns need naps and
they need sleep and y'all are going to
be up all night all night and how are we
going to manage this are we going to be
able to hire somebody to come be a
sitter that's going to help out even
though I'm a stay-at-home mom I'm gonna
need some support and some help even
though you're working from home Phil you
still got to work right how are we going
to manage a overwhelming situation and
taking care of a 70 year old guy with
bipolar disorder and an 18 year old
who's really upset and sadly lost his
mom and a 14 year old and 11 year old
how so how are we going to keep our
nuclear family
how are we going to take care of the
needs of two infants basically is what
I'm saying
um and then we're going to be really
clear about what our goals are meaning
what does help mean
and I think
um you've probably heard me if you ever
listen to the show I used to say it all
the time talking about pictures and
words
but my guess is
Faith you have a picture of what help
looks like
and I'm gonna be real reductionistic and
real General General right here okay and
so I'll make it this wrong and I might
mix up the gender roles and all that I'm
just making an example so I'm not trying
to be ugly or anything okay Faith you
may have a picture of help
is this time next year everyone in the
family is sitting around having
Thanksgiving
um you've got this almost one-year-old
in one of those little Papoose pouch
things and you're making dinner because
you're a homemaker and you love it and
your husband comes it out of the study
he's working from home and your bipolar
father who's stable on his meds he
high-fives him he's like man you're a
great husband my daughter won the
lottery when she married you like you
had this picture of help
and your husband Phil Phil you might
have a picture of help which is I need
you
father-in-law to get a job and I need
you to not be in the house I need all
the kids to be quiet while I'm at work
because I'm working from home now
and I'm gonna need fill in the blank and
so help is going to look like six months
where we're gonna do this we're gonna
get everybody back on their feet I'm
gonna help Dad get and what we're gonna
have is we're gonna have two people
saying we need to help we need to help
we need help we need help and you're
gonna be saying two completely different
things with that with you by using that
same word
so I want you all to get together in
this Retreat I'm proposing and be very
crystal clear
to The Last Detail what does help mean
what are our goals by moving into this
house what are we going to accomplish by
by coming here
and then as a part of that what can we
actually do
if Dad starts yelling what are we gonna
do
if Dad says I'm not taking my meds
what are we gonna do
if that 18 year old
hit somebody what are we gonna do right
so we sell our house we're all in I want
to be very clear about planning some
things on the front end
so that we're not surprised and we freak
out and then we get surprised and we get
freaked out we make rash decisions along
the way
does that make sense
yeah and then we're going to communicate
those very very clearly to Dad
and possibly if he would do it with
dad's counselor so that he's got some
non-parents like he's got some
accountability that doesn't include his
daughter and her and the guy who's
keeps getting his daughter pregnant
right
yeah
and I said that on purpose because
there's that c there's that sense in
there right so all that to say is have
saying Hey Dad we aren't you are paying
for your groceries
or you are going to contribute 500 a
month and we will do the shopping you
will do your laundry
or otherwise Faith you're going to
become the pseudo mom to a thousand
people
and try to raise a newborn on two hours
of sleep a night and Phil you are going
to be the breadwinner of a whole bunch
of people in a whole bunch of house and
by working from home down the hall from
a screaming infant an exhausted wife and
a Bonkers 11 year old and a pissed off
18 year old and a dad who won't take his
meds
see what I'm saying see what I'm saying
yeah now I am not in any way saying
don't do this
at all I just want everybody to be clear
yeah okay there is no way that this
isn't very hard
but I don't know anything on Earth it's
not
really that's really good that isn't
also very hard
okay so let's be very crystal clear
about who we're gonna be what our
marriage is going to look like what our
parenting is going to look like what
kind of help we can provide what kind of
help we're willing to provide what are
our boundaries and how are we going to
communicate them
and let's just be really clear about
that and if at any point you say oh this
doesn't work like this in this house
that's a good conversation to have
and I would suggest that anybody that is
encouraging you from outside of your
family's unit outside of you and Phil
outside of you in faith
you know I think it'd be a good idea if
y'all just moved in with your
father-in-law I mean he looks like he
that's real real easy to say if you're
not moving in with your father-in-law in
his three young kids
right
and so it's simple to to lob uh we call
them uh it's simple to LOB
uh
charity grenades on somebody man you
should give them your car
you should give them your you should
just let them have that other house of
yours well cool thanks that's that's
easy you should just sell your house and
move in
maybe maybe and if you've been
thoughtful about it you've been
obviously
um y'all are very prayerful people and
you've considered that deeply
um man go all in go for it
like my buddy's a Navy SEAL like they
don't look at the at the task log they
don't look at the mission and be like ah
this is too hard no man it's real real
hard that's why you're a Navy SEAL and
we're gonna be very specific about the
challenges that we're gonna face and
we're gonna be very real we're gonna own
reality about what we're going to be
facing and then we're gonna be very very
very specific about how we're going to
overcome each one of those obstacles and
that's what I'm suggesting you do here
y'all are Navy Seals faith and Phil
Navy Seals except you're not you're just
a really incredible daughter
and a otherworldly son-in-law
who loves his father-in-law and he's
still grieving from the loss of mom
he wants to see those three kids be well
and whole they want to just be great
people so I'm proud it's awesome it's
good to get to talk to you know you
but let's be sober and let's be
clear-eyed about what we're walking into
so that
we can have the identity that we're
going to be people who are well from
people who are whole I'm going to keep
uh this thing the Train on the tracks
here
so that
we can quote unquote help we'll be right
back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your features out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show in
honor of the great Elton John's final
U.S concert this past weekend
and
for the great Chris Wright
who is originally and most importantly
known as one of the guitarists
of dump button the greatest bands that
has ever existed also otherwise known as
Kelly's boss and yada yada yada but
he's a huge Elton John fan and he
specifically picked this song and when
your leader tells you can do something I
guess that's how Kelly rolls that's how
she rolls so the song is called Mona
Lisas and Mad Hatters that should be the
name of this show that's fantastic
Elton John's Mona Lisas and Mad Hatter's
and it goes like this and now I know
Spanish Harlem are not just pretty words
to say I thought I knew but now I know
that rose trees never grow in New York
City until you've seen this trashcan
dream come true you stand at the ledge
while people run through and I thank the
Lord there's people out there like you I
thank the Lord there's people out there
like you
faith and fill I thank the Lord there
are people out there like you
amazing and you are too America thanks
for listening we'll see you soon
[Music]